After nine seasons, the CW's "The
Flash" has finally ended its run.
Now that the show has crossed the finish line,
what's next for our favorite speedsters? Here's
the ending of CW's "The Flash" explained.
Fittingly, "The Flash" is an extremely
fast-paced show. Villains and storylines
move in and out at rapid speed. Even
before the four-part finale event,
Barry actually dies in Episode 9 at
the super-vibrating hand of Wally West,
who is under the influence of
Ramsey Rosso's toxic zombie cells.
Luckily, Barry ends up in a woodsy
afterlife area where Oliver Queen
hangs out. As part of his posthumous
duties as the Spectre, Oliver is able
to bring Barry back to life. He's even able
to return to the land of the living himself,
but only as long as the multiverse is in
peril or there's an after-party to attend.
"The perks of being the spectre."
While all that is going on, Khione,
still discovering her powers,
freezes all the water in the toxic zombie
bodies of Team Flash, incapacitating them,
then reanimates John Diggle so he
can help Flash and Arrow as Spartan.
Episode 10 of "The Flash" begins with a mystery
man, but soon cuts to Iris who's still battling
early-term morning sickness and is days
from labor. Iris gets a text about winning
the Pulitzer, but Barry, who is baby proofing the
apartment, vanishes in a bolt of blue lightning.
He's transported back to the date his mother
is killed by the Reverse-Flash Eobard Thawne.
Adult Barry has been here before, but now he is
able to spend more time with his parents. Sadly,
this is also the moment he has to be
the one to tell his former self not to
intervene in his mother's death. Eobard
kills her and is trapped in the past,
closing the loop Barry has
revisited throughout his life.
However, a sinister force bigger
than Reverse-Flash is at work,
and it possesses Joe through a large blue
crystal. It's the Negative Speed Force essence,
forcing Joe to fight Barry. Barry uses his
lightning rod connection to Iris to center himself
and separate Joe's consciousness from the crystal,
saving both their lives. The crystal disappears.
Meanwhile back in Central City, a
large cloud of red lightning flashes
in the sky and strikes the mystery
man in the chest. When he wakes,
he finds the confidential police file on
Eddie Thawne, who looks exactly like him.
Khione avoids the pesky chore of
opening doors by turning herself
into mist and wafting in underneath.
She speaks to her plants and journals,
but the person she really wishes
she could talk to is Mark.
"These last few months, there were so
many things I wanted to talk to you about.
I guess you just didn't want to talk to me."
Coincidentally, Mark is back, except he's
actually the Negative Speed Force's current
vessel. He berates Khione, causing her
to flee, then attacks the rest of Team
Flash in her and Barry's absence, as
the latter is still trapped in time.
Speed Force Nora counsels Khione on
her powers. She doesn't understand
them yet but can feel the whole
world at once. Speed Force Nora
responds that it sounds like Khione
understands her powers very well.
Khione confronts the possessed Mark and
with a snap of her fingers reduces his
entire body — save the crystal — to dust.
The crystal vanishes before she can grab it,
so with another snap, she reassembles Mark.
Cecile senses intense panic and joy, which
can only mean that Iris is in labor. Barry
manages to return at exactly the right
time, and everyone heads to the hospital.
Across Central City, the Eddie
doppelgänger goes to CCPD for answers
but his looks stun everyone speechless.
As he starts recalling Eddie's memories,
he realizes he is Eddie resurrected. He
digs up Eddie's empty coffin to prove it
and pulls the fatal bullet out of his own
chest. A singularity cloud opens above.
"What the hell?"
Barry is pulled to 2049. Previously, Barry didn't
exist in 2049, having vanished in the Crisis
of Infinite Earths. In this episode, however,
2049-Barry exists and is simply away in space.
The blue crystal is also there and has possessed
Nora. When Eddie, transported by the Negative
Speed Force, wanders into the museum looking
for Barry, the possessed Nora tells him Barry
stole the life Eddie should have had, but
Barry zips in and takes Eddie out of there.
Back at Eddie's place, Barry notices
everything is covered in tachyons,
which means they're inside the Negative Speed
Force. Eddie is persuaded by all that negativity
and won't listen to Barry's reasoning. He feels
his sacrifice was wasted and goes to see Iris.
Cecile projects her 2023 consciousness into
her 2049 body to save Nora from possession.
With little trouble, she forces the temporal
body of the Negative Speed Force out of Nora's
physical form. She accepts her superhero name,
Virtue, but the crystal disappears once again.
Meanwhile, Iris tells Eddie that
Barry was always between them,
that her love for Barry was there
even when she wouldn't recognize it,
and that the family they built is the
life she was meant for. Infuriated,
Eddie goes back into the Negative Speed Force
and accepts the crystal, becoming its new avatar.
This is not the first time "The Flash"
has featured the Negative Speed Force,
so while it's a fitting antagonist for the
end of the series, it portends an unending
cycle that hardly indicates closure. The first
three parts of "A New World" follow that formula,
as each episode features a new member of Team
Flash being possessed and saved by another member.
It's essential that Barry finds a way to
break that pattern. "Reunions" closes the
loop on Barry's past, fulfilling the destiny
revealed all the way back in Season 1 — he's
fighting Reverse-Flash when his mother
is killed, and he dissuades his other
Flash-self from intervening. In order for the
show to end, it needs to close this loop of
conflict between the positive and negative
forces surrounding Central City as well.
The other major character development over the
first three parts of "A New World" involves
Khione. She has rapidly accessed powers above and
beyond anything she ever thought was possible,
and certainly beyond anything her alter-egos
have done before. Her recognizing these changes
and admitting to being a goddess implies
huge changes ahead. Khione herself warily
accepts that she will have to leave Central
City for good. She can't just help these few
people in this one place — she must be
everywhere, for everyone and everything.
"The more I embrace who I truly am, the
more I see the natural order of things."
Episode 4 has a lot of ground to cover, so the
show wastes no time in bringing back some dearly
departed foes. Zoom and Godspeed appear and nearly
come to blows when Eobard Thawne comes downstairs
to snarkily put them in their place. Savitar
arrives too, and Eddie — calling himself Cobalt
Blue — introduces himself, saying he brought
them all here to defeat Team Flash together.
That doesn't quite happen. In fact, the
battle ends quickly with Nora tricking
Savitar, Virtue mind zapping Godspeed, Allegra
unleashing ultraviolet energy onto Wells-Thawne,
and Khione knocking out Zoom with his
own lightning. Eddie, meanwhile, gets
redeemed just in time for Barry to return to the
hospital as Iris is ready to deliver their baby.
The second half of the episode
is all celebration and goodbyes,
with people across several different
timelines and multiverses there to see
the new baby. Even Harrison arrives to tell the
goddess Khione that she must prepare to ascend.
Barry closes things out by sending
lightning to three future speedsters.
Titled "A New World, Part Four: Finale,"
the last episode embraces several themes.
One is allowing positive and negative forces to
exist in concert instead of clashing. This idea
carries into society at large, where opposing
viewpoints frequently lead to violence. The
show asserts that disagreements are inevitable,
but ultimately, we are all trying to improve
things for ourselves and our loved ones. That, in
and of itself, is a goal everyone can recognize.
"The Flash" also focuses on family, as Nora's
birth is a throughline of all four episodes
of "A New World." As Barry battles across time,
it's his love and relationships that center him
and give him strength. Even the redemption of
Eddie comes from the recognition of his past;
his enduring love and belief in doing the
right thing allows him to die honorably.
Farewells also come into play, for the show and
for Khione, who is taking her place in the ether
as protector of the natural world. She tells the
team that she is also abandoning her mortal body
as well. In her place stands Caitlin, who died
unnaturally and therefore, according to Khione,
deserves her own second chance. And second chances
have always been a central theme in "The Flash."
In the denouement of the Flash finale, Eddie
is drained of power by Jay Garrick's Flash
in the middle of Jitters. Eddie
recharges himself with his fallen
Legion and enters the Negative Speed
Force to amplify his speed even more.
As this was how Eobard himself once
died, it seems Eddie is doomed too.
Khione tells Barry that she
can send him to confront Eddie,
but to what end? If Barry wants to
save Eddie — who once sacrificed
himself for Barry — then Khione tells
him he must change his perceptions.
Barry has always known balance to come
with strife, but Khione opines that it's
"about coexistence, not in conflict, but in
mutual trust." Barry finds this impossible,
because even if he refuses to fight, his enemies
continue to come after him. She tells him,
"Then you need to believe in the impossible,
because it's the only way
to create a better world."
Barry repeats that message to infant
Nora, saying the lightning chose him,
but now he is choosing to share that
gift with others. He sends his lightning
to future speedsters, hoping to grow
a better world and break the cycles.
In the Negative Speed Force with Barry for the
final time, Eddie lashes against him with blow
after blow, letting his fury overtake him. He even
starts to sound like Eobard, continuing the cycle
that has played out time and time again. Barry
picks up on this and he tells Eddie what a good
man he is, and how he is becoming the very person
he once sacrificed himself to defeat. He tells
Eddie that he is the Negative Speed Force's avatar
now, and he doesn't have to give in to the hate it
builds around him. He can fight it. Eobard Thawne
lived and died in hate, but Eddie has known love.
As he says this, Eddie is flooded
with memories of his previous life,
his happiness, and finally how Iris cried
over him as he died. His final words expressed
how he had always wanted to be her hero.
Present-day Eddie is moved by these memories,
so he pulls the crystal from his
chest and smashes it on the ground.
Although Eddie will always be
part of the Negative Speed Force,
he vows to work with Barry, instead of
against him, for the good of the world.
In Season 3 of "The Flash" Iris tells Barry,
" ... wherever you go, you'll always
be Barry and I'll always be Iris,
and we always find each other."
Those words are remembered again as the couple
celebrate the birth of their first child,
Nora. Now a happy trio, they look
forward to many more years together,
which seems almost guaranteed. In 2049
the two are still setting off sparks when
Graying Iris gets to talk with 2023 Barry.
Their love is palpable and everlasting.
Iris, of course, has won one Pulitzer and will go
on to win at least one more, while Barry chooses
to share some of his Flash powers with new heroes.
Of course, that doesn't mean he's going to stop
fighting crime himself. As we learn in "Part
Three," in the future, the Flash is sometimes
needed in space, while on Earth he and Eddie try
to work together to maintain the natural order.
Furthermore, even though Barry says watching their
daughter Nora hold her infant self is "trippy
even for us," Nora assures them that her little
brother Bart's birth will be even more eventful.
Joe can barely hold back tears as he marvels at
how much Iris has grown. She's a mother herself
now, and he feels amazing about how lucky he
is to have lived this life. Riding that high,
he finally proposes to Cecile,
praising her accomplishments.
"And I know that wherever our dreams may take
us, we will always keep loving each other."
This reinforces what Chuck tells her
in "Part Three," when she worries that
her long absence from Joe in 2049
must mean something goes wrong.
Chuck, meanwhile, is attacked by Reverse-Flash
during part four of the finale. He's saved by
Allegra but weirdly came out of the attack
unscathed because of the black hole energy
he absorbs during his experiment in
the Season 6 premiere. He's now a
Consciousness-Honed Universally Neutralized
Kerr anomaly, or C.H.U.N.K., and in 2049,
he and Allegra are long married but
still hot and heavy for each other.
The time-traveling Harrison Wells
has words of advice for Khione. He
tells her that time traveling isn't what
matters for people like them. What matters
is keeping pieces of your loved ones
with you wherever…and whenever you go.
Khione takes this to heart and
while Mark is sad to see her go,
he's grateful she never gave up on him. He's
also surprised and happy to see Caitlin back,
but Caitlin, for her part,
is eager to get back to work.
Talking with Entertainment Weekly, Grant
Gustin spoke about his own life changes
during the latter seasons of "The Flash," and
his desire to see Barry go through similar
new experiences. He felt that he and Barry went
through similar ups and downs across the years,
in similar stages of their lives,
so the timing felt natural to him.
"Arrow" star Stephen Amell also spoke with EW
about how "The Flash" finale means an end to the
Arrowverse as well, and how happy he is that "The
Flash" is the show to see it out. Furthermore,
he talked about his favorite scenes with Grant
as Oliver and Barry. One of his favorites was his
first appearance on the show, in the pilot,
when Oliver gives Barry his superhero name.
"Saving people…in a flash."
One of his other favorite scenes, however,
involved a simple drink at a bar
between Barry and Oliver. He said,
" [Season 9 showrunner Eric Wallace] wrote
this beautiful scene of the two of us sitting
there having a beer. If you go back and you
really pay close attention to the dialogue,
it's pretty much verbatim what I said to him in
the pilot of 'The Flash.' That was
a really neat full-circle moment."
With that, "The Flash" closes yet another loop.